- Lisa!
Ja, kein Problem. Ich habe noch genug
Deutschübungen, die ich machen kann.
Ich freue mich aber schon,
wenn du wiederkommst.
Wie ist denn der Urlaub?
Habt ihr tolles Wetter?
Toll! Das klingt super!
Das Wetter bei mir?
Ich glaube, es sind so um die
7 Grad und es ist bewölkt.
Abends soll es vielleicht noch regnen.
Und morgen wird es noch kälter.
Der Himmel ist einfach immer grau.
Ihr habt Sonne und 20 Grad?
Boah, das ist so gemein.
Du, Lisa?
Nico von der Party,
der bei euch gewohnt hat …
Der hat doch seine Tasche verloren?
Was hat Nico im Radio gesagt,
wie die Tasche aussieht?
Schwarz und ein Aufnäher
mit einem Fahrrad?
Wieso?
Naja …
Ich glaube, ich habe sie gefunden.